all right Merle and Steve Merlin Steve
you guys are
friends who connected in a very
interesting way
you guys have a fascination with
what do you call it
serial killer collecting memorabilia
life yeah I don't really know what to
call it but
um I'm a I'm a fan of um GiGi Allen and
the murder junkies and through meeting
Merle and you know and I am a member of
GG Allen in the murder Chucky he's his
brother and how we met
was
I was having like house sales I I had a
huge collection of serial killer and a
lot of my brothers uh Gigi Allen's
memorabilia and stuff like that
I was living in a three-bedroom house
by myself
paying all this rent money
to store all my stuff Museum so it was
basically kind of like a museum actually
the Museum of death here in Hollywood
they've got some of my stuff in the
museum so you've had this this
inclination towards well I've been I've
been collecting serial killer stuff
since the late 80s so
um
how it started for me was I went to when
I was living in Boston I had gone to an
exhibit
at a place called The Primal plunge it
was kind of like a little you know uh
underground bookstore and they had an
exhibit of all John Wayne Gacy's
paintings and artwork and stuff like
that so I went to that and I was totally
fascinated from from the very beginning
I was like I got to get into this I
gotta write to this guy I gotta start
like collecting some of his artwork well
not
you don't ever go into it
writing a letter to someone and say oh
hey I like your art can you send me some
artwork no you have to build some kind
of relationship and some kind of rapport
with them you know just right A lot of
people
write to these people and think oh I'm
just going to ask them for artwork it
doesn't work that way you probably won't
even get a letter back you know you got
to build up a relationship with these
people one of the subjects one of the
type of type of individual I would love
to do an interview more than anything
are the women who end up
getting in romantic relationships with
these guys that are on death row
that happens all the time or in prison
for their whole lives are like that too
there's a lot of guys who have the same
attraction and it may not be sexual it's
just this attraction to the uh the bad
guy yeah what what is that so what is
the attraction to this kind of stuff
for me I I love horror movies I love
Gore I love death I love watching the
news because hey where do you see like
stories about people dying and getting
killed and this that and the other on
the [__] news it's the best [__]
show on TV you know so
you know it all all of that stuff
it just you know you start with that and
then you like go okay well serial
killers and when I went to the John
Wayne Gacy exhibit I started writing to
him
and you know it's it was just a thrill
of getting a letter from someone I'm
from Chicago and I remember John Wayne
Gacy yeah the whole case was like it was
going on on streets that I knew very
well
so it started out just you know like a
thrill and I was doing it long before
the internet long before it became like
[__] mainstream because now there's
like 10 or 15 [__] channels on your
TV that have nothing but true crime on
every [__] night I have to literally
tear myself away and put the Andy
Griffith Show on for an hour so I can
get some comedy relief because
my head gets so full of like death and
serial killers and [__] like that it's
like
no but I mean it's just nice every once
in a while to laugh and like have
something wholesome yeah so so I go from
serial killers to the Andy Gardens I
feel the same way with this this channel
so so you know that's how it basically
started for me I mean I I just started
it as kind of like a hobby you know and
after Gacy well Gacy did a painting of
my brother
he also did one for Todd Phillips for
the hated documentary and then I had him
do
um a wedding portrait
of me and my wife
and so in order to do that I had sent
him a bunch of photos
and uh
so he could you know because he didn't
really know what my wife looked like or
whatever and I sent him a bunch of
photos and when he was finished with the
painting he sent the painting and the
photos back but he kept one photo of my
wife's teenage brother
and we used to laugh about that all the
time we're like oh that's [__] that's
Casey for you yeah and uh the Charming
individual right yeah well he was he was
funny he was really not he was really
cool to write to he was he was funny
um
and he was always talking about how he
was innocent in his case and all that
you know but um
yeah after uh you know so I wrote to him
from 89 until
May 94 when he was executed and after
that
I was like okay well this is 1994 I took
me a couple more two or three more years
or whatever then I started
corresponding with Danny rolling
who was the Gainesville Ripper
and
I went from him to Henry Lee Lucas
to as a Shaw cross to Wayne Henley to
you know uh Son of Sam you know you name
them and uh other than you know the big
names like Dahmer and people like that
that really didn't write to many people
you know but but back in those days this
was before you know this was the late
90s I started really corresponding with
more people
and and it was it was cool it was a lot
cooler back then because
it wasn't like you clicked the button
and you could buy something like you can
now you know or
you had to like know
the handful of people that were actually
in that scene because it was kind of
like people like looked at you like you
were a [__] weirdo the internet's
made everything more exciting you could
type someone's name in find out what
prison they're in what cell they're in
and yeah you know it's easier and back
then it was like okay I know this guy
that writes to this person let's trade
trade addresses or things like that
because
it was it was still very underground you
know and and I remember when people
would come to my apartment and looked
like you're into that [__] you're like a
sick [__] you know it's like and now
it's like
everybody's into it
all the time I think Johnny Depp had a
Casey too yeah yeah so Steve you're
what is your fascination with this I
mean you got into it later than
um just growing up I've always been to
the uh darker side of life
um being always being into like his
brother's music and his music the murder
junkies and hanging out with Merle
seeing how kind of you know like he said
you learn from someone you know how it
can be done and it becomes kind of fun
and I got into it and to the point where
I brought a little example here there's
like a quarter of some of my letters
right here I got a whole closet full of
binders they're just packs of letters
and uh it becomes overwhelming but it's
fun
see I had I had the those binders too
you know back in the day but as I was
saying before when I was living in the
three-bedroom house
I decided to start selling my stuff
because I was like I'm paying all this
money to live in this big house by
myself with all my collection and I
finally began to realize
you know before it this was still before
it got really
to the extent of the popularity that
it's at now
I started selling pieces and I saw this
piece and that piece on
at the height of my collection I think I
had about a hundred pieces of artwork
paintings drawings stuff like that and I
pieced it out one at a time sold
everything started selling my letters
and I downsized from the three-bedroom
house to a two-bedroom house in Long
Beach and because I was having house
sales too and this is how I met Steve he
came to my house sale in Long Beach him
and his wife and little Duke you know
what the [__] are these guys now
and he was like all excited about buying
merch and stuff like that and then he uh
saw some of the series The small Ramirez
note sitting on the table was really
small and I looked at I go who's that I
looked at the name I said Richard in the
corner I go Richard who he says Ramirez
I'm like oh man that's cool and that
kind of like sparked it for me and is
there any common trait all these
uh inmates will have
the serial killers
yeah they want your money they want your
[__] money you know it's it's a game
man it's like a [__] game they're
celebrities they want something and you
want something it's basically like a
trade you know and
you know you can develop I mean I
developed like real friendships
with certain people I mean there were
certain serial killers that were total
[__] boars to write to Richard
Ramirez everybody puts Richard with
[__] Ramirez on a [__] pedestal oh
he's so great he's a [__] dirty
scummy smelly
disgusting [__] human being his
letters what boring as [__]
but I collected him because he was
Richard Ramirez you know and Merle had
the cool stuff the stationary with like
the where he signed Night Stalker at the
bottom with the blood drips and stuff he
got to the point where he couldn't do
that no more because of the guards
didn't like that so
so where did this start for you guys was
there anything in your childhood that
made this fascinating to you
it's an unusual
well I grew up in a log cabin in the
middle of the woods in New Hampshire so
believe me there was nothing going on in
my life for the first 10 years until my
mom was smart enough to divorce my
father and then we and then life began
for us
you know because we were very isolated
and very you know my father was a total
[__] recluse a total nut job [__]
[__] you know so when my mother
finally got away from my father was when
we became free you know because before
that
we literally grew up in a two-room log
cabin with no running water and it was
pretty rough you and your brother
thank you and your brother yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so and you got any music well you know
what got us into music was 1964.
The Beatles first episode on The Ed
Sullivan Show and
my mom loved music my dad liked music
too so uh I remembered them
I remember the Ed Sullivan Show came on
late at night
and my mom let us get out of bed so we
could watch The Beatles on The Ed
Sullivan Show and that was it we saw the
Beatles on The Ed Sullivan Show and we
were like that's what I want to do when
I grow up you were the only one of them
thank you you weren't the only one yeah
well yeah exactly yeah all generation
yeah let's see we were we were
secluded and isolated and that was 64. I
think my mom left the year after and
that's when we were able to open up and
see the world and see everything that
was out there you know and we had my mom
had a friend who had a daughter that was
a few years older than we were because
we were only 10 9 10 11 years old at the
time
and she was into all the British
Invasion music so we were listening to
like stuff like the Yard Birds and the
Dave Clark Five and the tremolos and the
easy beats and all that [__] you know
and uh that's how our music
Al career kind of got started you know
were you always fascinated with darkness
and oh God yeah yeah you know as soon as
I started watching horror movies at a
really young age I remember going to
like Drive-Ins and [__] and watching
horror movies and having a hitchhike
calm afterwards sometimes you know and
be like oh [__] man you know and like
you're in New Hampshire in the middle of
nowhere you're like and your your
brother was the same yeah me and my
brother did a lot of hitchhiking and
traveling you were both fascinated with
that kind of stuff yeah yeah and Steve
what about you yeah
um just growing up I was the oldest of
all the kids and Ike was kind of the one
to like watch over making sure we were
watching things we shouldn't watch and a
lot of times we're watching horror
unfortunately I wasn't watching some
kids just have a Fascination for that
stuff yeah and then they got to the
point where like I liked collecting
stuff and you know when it got to that
took over
what's your favorite
piece from your collection
um I got a letter from Ted Kaczynski the
Unabomber
um
that's probably my favorite one I got
because for some reason just having that
like knowing that from from him was kind
of wild I mean you understand there were
people that were murdered their kids
were murdered
by these people yeah and I don't like I
don't like look at them like they're
great or like someone I look up to as
far as like oh that's great what they
did it's just kind of like when you go
to the zoo and you see like something
that's like a poisonous like snake or
something you're admiring it
to ask for what it is yeah I get that
I get that
he said so your collection
is is mainly letters
artwork letters hair
um sometimes they'll send like
fingernails they'll send pretty much
anything they can send pieces from the
cell they've chiseled off and they want
to throw it in there you have to pay for
these items no I mean to be honest I've
worked relationships with these guys to
where I don't really pay for anything
what uh what's the most you've ever sold
anything for more
sold
oh God I saw my brothers uh Gacy
painting of my brother for six grand and
then uh well actually one day I sold two
or three paintings so I made like 12
000. that was like my biggest day but
the funny thing is that some of the
people that bought stuff from me way
back in the day when they had money
that they've come to need money now with
the way the world is and so they're so
and plus they you know once you've had
something for
for me anyway once once I've had
something for 5 10 20 years I'm tired of
it I want to you know so that's why I
started to sell all my stuff
was
plus I realized that it was worth money
you know and when I like like I said in
the beginning when I started collecting
it was all just for fun I didn't do it
thinking you know 20 years down the road
I was gonna make my retirement money
from it you know uh
I don't even know where my what my point
of so you you guys are both married
I'm not married [__] that [__] I'm
married you're married yeah he's that's
why he's the miserable [__] because
he's married Steve tell me how your wife
she hates it um she tells me that it
needs to be out of the house she doesn't
want to see it um I can't wear shirts
like this outside the house you gotta
check me underneath my sweater make sure
I'm not hiding anything
uh this one it's a GiGi Allen shirt
expose yourself to kids it's one of his
greatest songs
but um you're what your wife tolerates
it but she's like the filter because I
have two kids and uh she makes sure that
you know they're kind of away from it to
where they're not being exposed to you
know things they shouldn't be exposed to
at a young age yeah but you're not
you're not going in and out of prison or
on drugs or anything like that no but
foreign
at least yeah
Jail's different than prison right right
well yeah I haven't tried my best to uh
keep it under wraps and not expose you
know my family to it because they don't
like it they don't like it your wife is
uh a little more conventional yeah yeah
she she thinks I'm I'm disgusting for
this but and I'm a bad influence he's a
bad influence oh my God I'm a bad
influence I don't do drugs I don't do
anything [__] up you have a you have a
revolver tattoo on your temple well yeah
what's on what's on top of your head
who's that my brother oh wow yep
and have a nice piece on the back show
me your back
you have to sit down ah
there we go oh that's cool
yep
so I've been married too and and I've
been fortunate well
listen if I'm gonna have a woman if she
doesn't like what I'm into then I'm not
going to have a [__] woman I'm not
going to [__] play that like you
can't wear this [__] you I'm doing what
I [__] want to do if you want to be
with me that's fine if you don't hit the
[__] highway I'm sure there are
plenty of women that are yeah I'm not
worried about you could be fascinated
with this stuff oh yeah yeah
it's it's a lot easier to be fascinated
with it nowadays because it's it's
everywhere you look I mean you know yeah
the whole serial killer there's a whole
violence of this country school
shootings all that stuff you know school
shootings and all that [__] I mean you
know when I was collecting there was no
internet there was none of that [__] now
it's like it's it's almost cool that's
why I'm kind of just
do you have any theories on why why it's
becoming more common
just because of the news and because you
know one person does something then
somebody else wants to do something a
little more to top them and so everybody
wants their 15 minutes of fame right
and plus I mean people are just crazy
you know and people that I mean there
are mentally ill people that don't get
any treatments they're there's
you know people out there that
that need help that don't that aren't
able to get it or just don't know how to
get it you know yeah it's a common some
of these guys are like you would say
like Monsters and some of them are just
like regular people like you and me who
made a couple wrong decisions and got
themselves there so it's kind of fun to
get in the minds of the people who are
more of like Monsters but you do kind of
get the sense of people who are just
like normal people who just got there
you know it's not too hard to put
yourself in prison for life it's pretty
easy yeah and you get people that are
bullied and [__] like that you know and
hey after a while you've had enough you
know I mean
there's just a lot of [__] going on in
the a lot of [__] up [__] going on in
the world and people
a lot of people just can't handle it I
guess yeah it's a stressful world yeah
yeah lonely yeah it's a lot more
stressful than when I was growing up I I
honestly would never want to be
a kid in this [__] world today I'm
really happy that I grew up
in the 60s 70s I got to see all the best
music
see all the best of everything you know
because pretty much I'm I'm bored with
everything nowadays nothing really
excites me anymore you think the world's
going down the tubes oh [__] yeah it's
been going down the tube for years look
who our [__] president is
[__] sleepy ass [__] that don't even
know his own [__] name can't even
finish a [__] sentence half the time
and I don't even want to get started
about it I won't ask so who else do you
have in your binders here you have Casey
oh man pretty much I mean name someone
you know it's like that I have pretty
much everyone
you know he's got a really amazing
collection it's like Pokemon you gotta
catch them all
I mean when I was collecting it was you
know there was x amount of people
that you wanted to get you know now
there's so many of them it's I mean I
wish I was I wish I had started
collecting well maybe not wish but you
know if I was collecting now I would
have a lot more like Steve Steve's got a
really great collection I befriended the
the BTK dentist Raider for some time and
I have a lot of cool letters and artwork
from him so you know you get these
relationships with people and you get
these like personal things like mementos
and artwork and stuff and it's cool to
hold on to like Merle said but
eventually you know people want to buy
it it's it's interesting and it's
monetary value in the future and I don't
want to think of it like that but in a
way it is because you know things get
value over time and this stuff
apparently he's got gold in those he
said your childhood was was abnormal uh
like foster care
um split up the kids split up parents
divorced so it's just like you know
dealing with that and then middle school
then in Middle School Columbine so I had
that like as far as oh wow that happened
I went to high school and then 9 11 and
it's just like I feel like with the news
and everything it's so chaotic there's
so much chaos that sometimes I feel like
talking with these people kind of makes
me realize that the world is chaotic and
it's just you have to be like peace and
love in the midst of violence you know
something in the middle yeah you can't
pretend it doesn't go on
yeah
what would you guys say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
lives
I'm not sure I've learned it yet
I'm still learning to just be patient
let people talk and learn because I'm
still like I'm only 35 years old so
there's a lot for me to learn still but
um just patience yeah I have some people
I have very little patience for anything
anymore I stay home a lot
you know when when the pandemic started
and we were social distancing oh my God
that was so wonderful I couldn't [__]
I'm like geez I've been doing this for
my [__] like my whole life this is
great
I mean there's no traffic outside I mean
you know other than the fact that you
had to you know get to go to like two or
three markets to get some food and you
know hoard some toilet paper before
everybody else would you guys both
consider yourselves anti-social
I I'm I'm very anti-social unless I'm in
my own scene with like when we go on
tour like I have to be Mr social because
everybody wants to talk to you and
everybody wants a piece yeah but that
but that's a special but that's fine I
like that you know that's that's what I
live for you know but other than that
I'm
like I say I really don't go out very
often and you know I'll go to the market
I try to go to the market early in the
morning before too many people are there
uh or late at night when you know the
stalker people are stocking the shelves
the nice doctors yeah
you know but uh I mean I never even got
covered once because I basically just
stay away from people most of the time
so I gotta do it
that'll do it
all right Merle and Steve thank you so
much for coming in talking about what
you're
your side interests are
fascinating my pleasure thank you so
much you guys no problem thank you